in late November word had already gotten
off of the mainland that there was a
virus in Wuhan six weeks later the trade
truce was signed with an out clause a
very clever out clause that said if
there was any kind of act of God
pandemic then they didn't have to make
good on what they had committed to buy
from the United States within days they
announced the first coronavirus the
World Health Organization should be held
accountable for not holding China
accountable to providing good valid data
so that the rest of the world could
prepare for fewer people to die to me
these are equivalents to acts of war on
the part of China what is a ripple
effect what happens to people what does
that go they're not working the same
hours maybe one of the two breadwinners
lost their job your 401k has been
decimated let me get this straight you
can constantly bail yourself out and you
can constantly go print money with this
quantitative easing why the hell do I
have to pay taxes the Federal Reserve
came riding to the rescue and said no no
go back to your spending ways borrow and
spend borrow and spend mortgaging
yourself up to the eyeballs how do we
give you if Donald J Trump is Steven
minuchin boss then Donald Trump is
running the Federal Reserve right now
that's not real money that's fake money
that's true and I'm sure you're not as a
fake money really how many laws are
being broken like I'm not an attorney
but I've lost count
the Socialists say that we can print as
much money as we want oh my gosh I mean
when does it ever end the Fed is both
arsonist and firefighter this is like we
need a drink right now yeah you need
something stronger than a memo let me
say that much 75 percent of Americans
have seen their income cut by at least
25 percent these are the seeds of social
unrest
did you ever think you would make it I
said I'm so like it takes sweet victory
I know this slice meant for me yeah why
would you bet on Goliath when we got fat
a p-value came in given values
contagious this world of entrepreneurs
we can't no value to haters happy run
homie look what I become
[Music]
so now he tenders a lot of you guys have
been talking about this whole
coronavirus you know pat what should we
be looking out for how can we be
prepared for it and many of you have
been talking about it from the economy
standpoint so we decided to bring in
economists to kind of see what the
effects are going to be in the person I
brought in today is a special one
because she got her MBA from a
University of Texas at Austin got our
MSN journalism from Columbia University
she was the adviser to Richard Fisher
who was a former CEO of the Federal
Reserve Bank of Dallas for nine years
and then she's been featured on Wall
Street Journal Bloomberg CNBC you name
it and she wrote a book I think 2017
that was published fed up and with that
being said my guest today Danielle
DiMartino booth Daniel thank you for
coming out and being a guest it's great
to be here so so when we get into this a
couple things I've seen your stuff with
your book I've seen your interviews I've
seen a lot of the talks you've given you
can go extremely technical and speak the
language of folks who are in that world
and then you can also go simple sure
today let's try to speak to the audience
of middle to simple to get a lot of us
educated on what's going on see some of
the people that aren't here over experts
in this area but most of us want to
learn a little bit more on what you know
so having said that we've not seen a
time like this in a long time what is
your biggest concern today when you see
all this stuff going on well so my
mother grew up in South Texas with her
grandparents who survived the Great
Depression so she's one of the few
Americans left who remember what it
means to save before you spend it is not
part of the American culture anymore but
nor in more than a hundred years have we
needed to be of this mindset or so at
least we thought there's always been
access to credit there's always been a
mortgage there's always been a car loan
there's always been a credit card if
you're kind of running straight down the
middle but I think what the coronavirus
is going to revive is kind of our
founding fathers their philosophy you
know if you don't plan ahead then you'll
fail to be if you don't prepare then you
you feel to be prepared this is Ben
Franklin I'm paraphrasing him but what
we're finding out with this economic
shock of the coronavirus is that so few
Americans are prepared so few Americans
have a rainy day fund set aside in order
to weather them one or two or three
months and that's problematic and it
gives me great hope at the same time
because I think we're going to return to
some of our more frugal roots in this
country which has vast implications for
the US economy how do we get here though
I mean you know obviously you know the
the the coronavirus is a form some call
it white swan' some call a Black Swan
because we have experienced some kind of
a pandemic before so we can't
necessarily call it a black smile like a
911 maybe it was a Black Swan but how do
we get to this point where our habits
are so much leaning towards debt and
Kasabian and that how do we get to this
point well I think it's it's been
something that has been encouraged by
Federal Reserve policy and by
politicians in America for generations
plural you know we came out of the 1980s
after the stock market crash which was
really just kind of a blip in a longer
economic cycle but we came out of that
with most of our leaders saying borrow
and spend borrow and spend things really
got cranked up kind of in the 80s with
the yuppies and the baby boomer
generation coming out and spending more
than they earned you know they were the
first generation to take on as much debt
as they did and we kind of saw this
hockey-stick of increase in credit card
debt for the first time that was
accepted across the country and you know
towards the end of the dot-com era I
mean we it's hard to even think back to
1999-2000 when everybody was trading
stocks and insider trading I'm excuse me
a day trading and you couldn't go in a
taxicab in New York without the taxi
drivers saying this is I got a hot stock
tip for you do you have a hot stock tip
for me that kind of imploded and Alan
Greenspan to resolve this took interest
rates to our
officialy low levels and kept them there
for a long time at the same time you had
financial innovation as are the words
that they use and all that means is
opening up the debt box to where you
know what were we saying at the height
of the last housing boom if you can fog
a mirror you can get a mortgage
there were people's dogs who were
getting you know the credit card
applications in the mail I remember late
on in the credit boom
I had a six-month-old son my firstborn
received a credit card application in
the mail its six-month got excited a
card application in the mail and that
was kind of the apex of people using
their homes as ATMs this was this was
you know what Jane and Johnny and Maria
they could all go to whatever college
they want to go to because I'll just
take the money out of the house to send
them we can go take the Disney vacation
we can't afford I'll take the money out
of my house and send him so the mortgage
bubble kind of took debt in America to a
whole new level and then that imploded
and we find ourselves over a decade
later and now in the current iteration
in the current cycle we've bought more
car than we can afford to drive buying a
$60,000 pickup you don't blink an eye
because maybe it's a 7 or an 8 year loan
term and as Americans I think we've kind
of lost our way because we don't look at
what we earn compared to what we can
afford we look at whether we can make
the payment and just get by and that
type of mindset is what has left an
entire the largest economy in the world
as Vollmer about as it is as this Black
Swan whites won't call it what you want
but that's what's left us so vulnerable
is that we've just done what we need to
do to just get by paycheck to paycheck
to paycheck and not set aside anything
and now we find ourselves with record
mortgage forbearance and people walking
away from this and that debt because
they have absolutely no choice how do we
get here on this sense of when I'm when
I'm asking this next question because
it's the symfon eyes before how do we
get here in the sense
is this our fault of people's faults or
is this the decision-makers fault on
making it looks kind of like the
following you know you are living in a
family and your dad lowers the standards
and it lets you do whatever you want to
do your parents let you kind of do
whatever they want to do and then the
kid goes out and says you know what I'm
gonna go try to smoke weed and this
other girl she introduced me to this
truck and I'm going to go out there and
party state till two o'clock in the
morning you're sixteen years of cuz no
one cares but is it our fault or is it
the decision-makers fault that we got
here I think placing blame is is
short-sighted because I think the blame
has to go around I think that
policymakers and the reason I wrote
fed-up in the first place is that at the
highest level especially if you're
economically vulnerable or if you're not
you don't know everything that there is
to know about finance it's not as if
they teach it in high schools much less
colleges as a requirement so Americans
aren't financially illiterate by the
design of our educational system so you
get the politicians and you get the
heads of the Federal Reserve and they
encourage this so you're saying well
that's a leader and a leader is telling
me how I should run my budget and so
they must be right Ben Bernanke you know
at the height of the housing bubble was
saying that that there's no way that
home prices decrease on on a nationwide
basis well that's not true it did happen
during the Great Depression but you're
being told by people who sound really
smart that you're making the right
decision and at the same time though you
have to go back and say hey you know
you're living from paycheck to paycheck
you realize it you know if you're not
setting any money aside for a rainy day
you know if you're sitting in the in a
car dealership and you're being
sweet-talked by the finance manager you
know that it might not be six hundred
dollars a month that you can really
afford it might be more like four
hundred and fifty dollars a month and
you tell yourself but they're gonna let
me do it and so I will so I think you
have to say that it was encouraged at
the highest levels and shame on them but
by the same token I think households
have deluded themselves for a while as
well because we've become an instant
gratification Society
that's a multi-generational statement by
the way I mean you've got an entire
generation of baby boomers living in way
more house than they need right now
their children may need it and maybe
moving back in with them but I'm not
trying to pin this on the Millennials
per se who are experience and spend all
of their their disposable income on
great vacations and the latest iPhones
now I think this carries across multiple
generations and I think that Millennials
learned a lot from their parents who
also lived beyond their means
so generationally so you're not saying
this is a government thing this is not
us because you know how you travel and
you go places I always travel when I go
places I asked the driver so tell me
about your house what's a house go for
here this much how much you financed
your house what do you mean how much is
your finance you know how much you
finance your house I didn't finance my
house you're at the Caribbeans what
didn't he didn't finance your house you
can't finance stuff here what does that
mean you can't find our stuff here if
you buy a house you have to buy it cash
yep what do you mean you have to buy
cash so if you don't have yeah like my
house right here 50 $50,000 my wife's
parents and my parents helped us and we
bought this out so you don't have any
payment on it we don't have any payment
on it right so that that's very normal
for a lot of people in different
countries right we're in the u.s. it's
kind of like well you know I can buy
that house and finance that ninety-five
percent or ninety percent over back in
the days mean a hundred percent you know
and my payments only gonna be two
thousand dollars a month and I'm
financing a $250,000 house that that
part to me is if we allow that to be the
norm well the people are gonna take
advantage of it okay so you know the
chicken and the egg story I'm curious to
know who started this standard because
there has to be somebody held
accountable to this year I run a company
if in our company a mistake happens or
we take a hit all the you know points--
you know everything's gonna be pointed
at me like I say well he's the CEO what
you do how come you to make the right
decision right how come you didn't go
raise more money out of town well you
know for crisis was gonna happen that we
could maintain our status and all this
other stuff fair enough on the seal
someone has to be held liable for the
yep you're an economist you're an expert
I know I read your stuff you try to be
as diplomatic as possible because you're
trying to respect your peers and the
industry you're part of who started this
I'm trying to figure out who is liable
for starting this mess so you know it I
would say that it goes back to a
democratic or a Republican
administration but the truth is when the
Community Reinvestment Act was was came
about first of all let's go back a
little bit further we're in Texas the
Savings and Loan scandal happened here
in the aftermath of this great crisis
where Texas was the epicenter you had
homes clear at fire sale prices so you
had mass foreclosures and but you also
had people come in and we're going to
live in the homes and buy them on the
cheap and then the market cleared and it
was ugly and it was messy but the market
cleared contrast that with politicians
really enjoying saying that owning a
home is the American dream and you can
cross that from Clinton to Bush all the
way on through Obama but the thing is
they were telling Americans that owning
a home was the American dream what they
were really saying was more to keep
mortgaging yourself up to the eyeballs
with the assistance of a federal agency
then you get to feel wealthy you're not
actually wealthy you've actually become
an indentured servant to this great big
mortgage market which is the largest
debt market on planet earth larger than
the US Treasury market I mean it's it's
multiples of the size of the US Treasury
market and politicians found out that
people enjoyed feeling wealthy even if
they weren't and again we were not a
country founded on the ideals of debt
equals prosperity no no you save you
invest you prosper and having Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac and the FHA extend
extend extend increase eligibility for
mortgages I mean when my when the
Vietnam War ended in San Antonio Texas
you know my parents bar
money from the parents and with the help
of a VA loan they barely got a mortgage
and it was known for their generation
that they were supposed to strive to pay
that mortgage off before they retired
you certainly don't go into retirement
with mortgage debt and yet here we are
in America today and the majority of
retirees still carry mortgage debt think
about that you're in retirement and
financially vulnerable I know it makes
it but it is what it is and it's the
culture that we have accepted and we've
been told by our leaders that it's the
way it should be who's questioning them
oh I think right now mother nature is
questioning them I think right now the
coronavirus is questioning them I think
that there is going to be a severe
cultural backlash where families feel
the pain enough to say and make
decisions on their own if they're
encouraged to take on debt sure we're
going to go back to our ways in a in
some sense of the word but there are
predictions right now that unemployment
could surpass that of what we saw during
the Great Depression I mean these are
unfathomable numbers that we're
considering in America during at the
apex at the height of the Great
Depression one in four Americans were
out of work in two weeks time two weeks
time we had 9.95 nearly 10 million
jobless claims in America in two weeks
time we got to one in 16 Americans and
what we know from studying Google Trends
you can you can track any word on Google
Trends right now if you track
unemployment insurance it's really
popular especially in Texas and in New
York and in other states where there's
been a tremendous backlog Florida is
going to be coming up big-time because
they have such an antiquated
unemployment insurance system that
people can't get through to file the
unemployment insurance claims that they
need to right now but what we know from
studying Google Trends is that the third
wave was even bigger than the first and
the second waves as other states went
into
shut down so we haven't seen the worst
of what we're going to see in terms of
the ranks of Americans who are
unemployed they took a survey just
overnight seventy five percent of
Americans have seen their income cut by
at least 25 percent in other words even
people who are keeping their jobs aren't
making the same amount sure they're not
working the same hours maybe one of the
two breadwinners lost their lost their
job you've got your kids at home online
schooling and you're trying to do your
job even if you are working remotely you
may as well be on your roof trying to
get your job done and inform a sentence
I'm a writer I mean I write and conduct
research and it's things work out really
well for me around 4:00 or 5:00 a.m.
when the whole house is asleep but this
is this is a cultural shift is what I'm
trying to say this is unlike anything
generations have seen since those who
survived the Great Depression so mother
nature is holding these people
accountable with coronavirus a cake or a
virus which and I'm not saying it's
revenge or anything about nature I'm
just saying it's it's shining a very
bright light I totally get it it's kind
of it's it's a it's highlighting a lot
of the things that they've been doing
that we haven't been prepared for and
now hey you're being held accountable
what are we gonna do now I get that part
when we read you know the articles that
say unemployment is projected by the end
of second quarter to be at 30% just kind
of you read it you're like yeah it's
gonna be at 30% you know you know you're
looking at the news it's gonna be at 30%
it's gonna be at 30%
let me skip the channel then I'm gonna
go to this next one 30% is 30% what what
does that really mean if you were to
unpack so and here's what I mean by
unpack 30% if we were to unpack 30%
consequences a ripple effect if we go to
30% 75% is minus 25% of income right now
of Americans
one out of four was unemployed back in a
great depression 30% means one in three
point three so we're gonna go into some
tough times
what is the ripple effects and what
industries what happens to people
economy safety what does that go what
could I look like so you're asking
key question here because for as large
as the fiscal stimulus is and we've
already got two trillion out there the
Federal Reserve's going to lever up by a
multiple of ten four hundred and fifty
billion dollars so that they can keep a
lot of businesses still in business some
of which may or may not deserve to go
out of business but we'll get to that
but the fact is from what we know today
the stimulus checks aren't going to hit
until when a lot of Americans have been
out of work for six weeks or more the
time the actual stimulus money hits
their accounts six weeks well it was
three weeks from the time of the signing
of when Congress passed the legislation
and it was signed into law and by then
there were plenty of Americans who had
been in shutdown for two or three weeks
so there have been a lot of people who
have been trying to get by on god knows
what that's why you've seen wealthy
restaurant tours in major cities open
their restaurants back up on their own
dime to feed people who don't have food
we're talking about red lines that you
read about in history class in middle
school people who don't have food and
let's let's stick with restaurants for
just a second the the percentage of
restaurants that are never going to
return never is tremendous what do you
mean by that
never going to return never going to
reopen never going to be able to find
the financing your average restaurant
has two or three days of cash flow on
hand a great restaurant maybe has one or
two weeks of cash flow on hand but
they've been asked by the government to
keep all of their employees employed and
wait for the Small Business
Administration loans to come through and
float them through to the end of
September a lot of business people in
America did the math and said this isn't
going to work and I can't tell you that
the demand is going to be there at the
end of the second quarter best-case
scenario I don't I you can't tell me
that as many Americans are going to go
out and spend the way they used to you
can't tell me that as many Americans are
going to go to
concerts go to the movies go to sporting
events go to music festivals get on
planes you know something of this
magnitude I mean there's a headline that
hit today there are more New Yorkers who
have died as a as a consequence of the
corona virus then what then what died on
9/11 you know I was I was in New York at
the time I worked on Wall Street at the
time it's something that reshaped my
life and the way I viewed the world now
magnify that spread that across a nation
we're gonna change the way we spend and
if we change the way we spend we're not
going to need to tap into as many
services as we once did as a nation so
what I'm trying to say is let's say we
get to 30% unemployment and let's say
the worst of the virus has passed that
doesn't mean the economy is going to
heal overnight it might take years and
that's what people are not factoring in
because if you have something of such
magnitude that it changes the way you
view the world and it changes the way
you view spending 2019 was an
extraordinary year in American history
business investment had clamped down
appreciably we had a trade war going on
in the background there was a global
economic slowdown China in the United
States weren't there weren't Chinese
people coming in and buying us home so
so there were a lot of things that
didn't occur in 2019 to offset it was
the American consumer was the US
household consumption is typically
two-thirds of the US economy that's the
way it's been urine and you're out for a
very long time in 2019 consumption was
90 percent of the US economy as the
Federal Reserve did everything they
could to elevate the stock market keep
risky asset prices up keep people
feeling wealthy because they look at
their 401ks and spend and spend and
spend and spend beyond their means
ninety percent of you
gross domestic product in 2019 was
consumption I can't tell you when we're
going to get back to a normal world of
two-thirds of the US economy being
consumption because of these massive
shock that this is placing on US
households and the way that they're
going to perceive money going forward is
going to be a tremendous change
so you're saying even after this we go
back to business as usual
the recovery is not going to be media
because you have two camps right now
right one camp is saying the moment this
thing clears it up we're gonna have the
economy's going to go back to $30,000
gonna hit 30th out everything's gonna go
back to you know business as usual
people gonna go back out and they're
gonna do what they're doing you're
saying no it's gonna take a while for us
to recover from this your argument on it
taking a while for to go back to
recovering from this is it based on the
fear people now have that's gonna take a
while to recover from still the concerns
of being around too much traffic we're
not gonna go back in the habit of going
to sporting events games are you saying
the habits and the fears of people's
gonna take us to go back to business as
usual are you saying more the financial
decisions we're making right now of
these businesses going out of business
going to take us to recover which part
are you kind of saying is it more
mindset or is there more business well
you you've described waves 1 and waves 2
there's going to be an initial reticence
and fear among people in terms of being
in in densely populated events where
whatever they may be
so that's your initial fear factor but
what I'm speaking of is what comes
behind this is a realization on the part
of your average working American that
they need to save more in the future
that they will never again wake up and
say why am i feeding my family ramen why
didn't I think to why didn't I set money
aside in my last life is that a good
thing oh I think it's eventually going
to be a great thing but it is going to
mean that there's that the coming
recession the recession that we are in
that we're in is going to be more
protracted and drawn-out than what many
are right now assuming as a base case
this could almost be like a filtering
process to take us back to the habits
that work you know it's are you saying
almost - you know how you talk to the
generation that came from the depression
they're always a little bit paranoid
they're always a little bit more worries
I know there are always a little bit
more like cautious you know when you
talk to people older they're always a
little bit more paranoid because they've
experienced a lot more things are you
saying that this generation may pick up
a little bit of the habit and a mindset
of the Great Depression generation of
being more paranoid than before because
if that's the case I actually don't
think that's a bad thing I I don't think
it's a bad thing and I think that it's
long overdue in this country but it's
going to change the way the economy
operates on a fundamental level you're
going to perceive if you right now are
stretching your dollar to fill up your
grocery cart when this is all said and
done even if your income goes back to
what it was before hmm you might not be
saying I want the high rise at Disney in
the full package for the family you
might get in the car and drive somewhere
and go camping if you're at the store
you might not say you know what I'm
gonna buy that lovely pork tenderloin
you might buy the pork chops you might
be more frugal in the way you approach
everyday purchases because you were
forced into being frugal because of this
because you were forced to overnight
make a budget and live within it how
different is that then oh wait because
even in all weight if you remember guys
were buying condos in Vegas for $700,000
$1,000,000 ah you know just put another
one I'll buy another one I'll buy
another one and everybody had an S 500
everybody had a nice car Porsche Ferrari
danwon all we'd have market tank 39
percent we're like I'll never do this
again so we kind of went back to good
habits for two or three years and then
we went back to her back
bad habits again how different is this
from that the difference is that the
government then was able to come in with
many programs and mortgage modifications
don't get me wrong there were 10 million
foreclosures in the United States it was
a tremendous hit but there
we're still many mitigation programs at
the time and the Federal Reserve had
actual traditional tools the Federal
Reserve was able to take interest rates
from four-and-a-half percent down to the
zero bound they were able to inject
stimulus into the economy whereas today
they're starting at the zero bound the
country had never known what a printing
press was the country had never known
what it was for the Fed to try and
inflate financial markets which they
successfully did they were able to come
in and keep zombie companies alive that
otherwise would have gone out of
business in a regular business cycle we
did have our wrist slapped but the
Federal Reserve came riding to the
rescue and said no no we're here we're
here to back you go back to your
spending ways maybe you can't get that
mortgage you wanted but by golly we're
gonna take interest rates down to the
zero bound we're gonna have private
equity investors come swarm into
neighborhoods buy up homes that
otherwise would have gone to millennial
first-time homebuyers for fire sale
prices that didn't happen you had
investors swarm in because anybody that
had deep pockets could borrow more with
interest rates at 0% you have the
government borrowed a kingdom come so
you had a very quiet expansion of the
social safety net so you ended up
keeping a large percentage of the US
economy of the US workforce
excuse me on the sidelines years later
we ended up with a with a skills with
with a lack of skills in the u.s.
workforce but part of that was also
because so many Americans were able to
stay out of the workforce and even
access credit all I'm saying is we have
companies that are still in business
today because the junk bond market
opened wide back open we have a lot of
the rot from the last financial crisis
that we were able to basically refinance
if you want to think about it that way
kick the can down the road not eliminate
or clean up just refunding not eliminate
not clean up keep the overcapacity in
the system keep more people employed
than the otherwise would have been
throughout the crisis
but you don't come out better and
stronger for it you just feel like you
have because you've taken on that much
more debt so that leads to a lot of
different questions we're gonna go to
negative interest rates because if
you're gonna form four and a half to
zero you know where you're gonna go from
zero to what that also brings me to
quantitative easing which we'll touch
about here in a minute and obviously the
Fed which will get to a hundred percent
but before we get there you know I have
a complete different thing that I was
curious what you would say so pre
coronavirus take coronavirus off the
table right I'm at a Goldman Sachs event
where the chief investment officer speak
in and she's eloquent be given a message
of how they foresee the economy being
and here's what's gonna happen we're not
too concerned about the coronavirus this
was at the beginning stages second week
of January to give them a credit it
wasn't like it was a second week of
February second week of January we're
not really thinking this is going to get
out of control the peanut you know the
are not score is not that high where
it's not gonna spread but take rotavirus
out go to 2019 were in July okay
us-china trade war still going on then
as well as still gonna go a little later
in December Saudi Arabia and Russia is
going on you know we have a wall go now
we have election going on we have the
divisive nests between Republicans and
Democrats going on we have a hundred and
twenty nine months of economic expansion
going on the greatest ever we've never
had 120 nine-month economic expansion
so if coronavirus doesn't happen set
that aside we don't have anything that
comes out of one we're going to go there
is no coronavirus today are we going to
get to where we are today regardless of
coronavirus or did coronavirus have to
happen for us to be in shambles that we
are today with the 2.2 trillion dollar
stimulus and they're projecting another
ten trillion dollars that's going to
come out possibly in the next month or
two so what's the difference so I think
the difference is magnitude and speed we
knew by looking at the data that things
were getting very very stretched and we
saw that if you took out fleet sales for
example I'll just take one example car
sales if you took out what the car
rental agencies and what corporate
corporation
we're buying for their own fleets if you
took that out you saw four years in a
row of declining retail car sales in
America if you looked at the employment
sector we got our last clean read pre
coronavirus this morning of job openings
we were seeing weakening on every front
of the job market prior to the groan of
iris hitting this was a very slow-moving
slowdown but it was definitely a
slowdown if we looked at data out of
Germany if we looked at data out of
China which pre coronavirus was was
growing at a 30-year low Germany was
slowing as well so and this is again
this is all pre coronavirus so would the
Federal Reserve have been able to float
the financial markets through the
election because they were so
aggressively keeping interest rates
artificially low levels and they were so
aggressively growing their balance sheet
even though they were calling it not QE
could they have floated the US economy
through the u.s. election possibly
possibly but we knew those of us who
worry about these things
knew that the bubble was getting to be
so big in the corporate debt market and
the bubble was getting to be so big in
the stock market that the littlest thing
and I've been saying this for probably a
year now that we are one financial shock
shy of the Federal Reserve having to
come in guns blazing and give a whole
new meaning one of my clients said the
Federal Reserve didn't come in with a
bazooka they came in with a neutron bomb
I agree
but that was what was required because
when you try and buy time and time as
the factor of time gets more expensive
that's what happens you inflate bigger
bubbles and we walked into this huge
coronavirus event more indebted as a
world and more in
as a country more indebted is a
corporate sector 74% of u.s. GDP almost
16 trillion dollars corporate debt
non-financial corporate debt in America
never seen these levels consumer debt
higher than it's ever been
remember what we talked about earlier if
you're joke you homeowner and the
mortgage company says no more No Mas
you may not take equity out of your home
cash out refinancings are over and yet
as a society we're still told we better
get that four-year degree so now we have
1.6 trillion dollars of student debt on
our hands because something had to pay
for it so student debts paid for it and
now we've seen credit card debt get back
up to over a trillion dollars and now
we've seen car loans get back up to well
over a trillion dollars so yes we don't
have the same amount of mortgage debt in
America as we did in 2006-2007 but boy
we've met up for it big time in other
areas so whether you're talking about
the world over 250 trillion dollars of
debt the US government corporate America
or US households we've all been up to
our eyeballs and drowning in debt again
that led to 15 questions but let me ask
one of them just out of curiosity the
world has 250 trillion dollars of debt
which is a lot of it is credit but we
only have around 50 trillion dollars of
currency how is that possible you know
what I'm asking right we have 50
trillion dollars of coins and currency
we have a quarter trillion dollars that
250 trillion dollars of debt we have a
lot of good faith based on the the
prowess of the US printing press I mean
the United States maintains reserve
currency status
that's very money though that's not real
money that's fake money that's true and
I'm sure your knowledge of fake money oh
really
I know but it's all based on faith how
long is this now how long is this
sustainable though to go at that pace in
theory and if you listen to what you're
being told everything's going to be ok
trillions and trillions and trillions of
dollars with the United States in the
lead the United States by far these are
the any other countries
taking on more debt to address the
coronavirus than anybody else on the
planet including China that's saying
something and we're being told that it's
all going to be fine because you can
just have the Federal Reserve which is
what they're going to do this year
finance all debt that's being taken on
put all of it on their balance sheet we
came into this with the Federal
Reserve's balance sheet somewhere in the
neighborhood of four trillion it is
likely that we will get into double
digits and trillion dollar it's a scary
thought you know I'm looking at all this
stuff and to me everything's the leaders
bulletin and I think someone's going to
come out the winner here from
coronavirus I do think oh this is
showing us that we need a strong leader
oh I think behind closed doors there is
and I'm gonna go to an empire that I'm
looking at that it's gonna be crazy for
me to give them credit but strategically
I think they have been poised for this
to come up so here's some data here
China's national debt is five point two
trillion dollars that's what they have
right and their GDP at their debt to GDP
but before I get into this how much do
you as an economist look at the debt to
GDP ratio is that a big factor do you
look at that as a big factor or not
really it's not a big concern I think
it's a huge concern it is so yeah and
now that we know that it's truly Milton
Friedman behind me I always adhered to
his philosophy that there is no such
thing as a free lunch you can buy time I
mean God knows we've seen a lot of time
purchased bought but we haven't seen it
paid for so yes I think that there will
be ramifications okay so when you're
saying that as an economist you do look
at nations and say Japan's at 221
percent debt to GDP ratio they're about
to have a massive recession taking place
that's gonna take them a couple decades
to recover do you go to extreme measures
when you see numbers like that or it's
not a measure point that you're looking
and say that's a very big factor well it
really is a country-by-country basis and
I don't want to I'm not trying to back
out of a question but internally in
Japan they own their own debt their
fates not necessarily tied to other
countries which means they're not
beholding to the kindness of strangers
unlike the United States where Japan
owns a trillion dollars of US Treasury
debt China owns over a trillion dollars
of US Treasury debt we assume
that we can take on as much debt as we
possibly can imagine and that our
borrowing costs will never go up because
we just assumed that we're number one it
to elaborate what you just said is that
is that in a sense of saying you know
we're married we have a family the bid
David family only borrows money from bid
David family
okay that's Japan but us the family here
borrows money from anybody strangers
whoever's I can't is that a mess good
way of putting over Japan versus us
because we're borrow from anybody and we
also borrow from ourselves and we the
Treasury issues it and the Federal
Reserve buys it so then if that's the
case let me give you this number and
tell me what you think about this
China isn't that five point two trillion
Brazil's that two trillion Japan's got
nine trillion and if you look at the
debt to GDP ratio Japan's at the top of
221 Greece 179 which would pretty much
know why Portugal 138 Italy 138 Belgium
115 u.s. 106 Spain 106 UK 86 France 98
point for Germany 62 you ready for this
number Russia 17% and they bought 400
tons of gold the last couple of years a
lot of these nations that have their
gold they've been sitting on the same
amount of gold for a while but Russia
has been coming up on the gold leaders
bulletin why are they at 17 percent
their debt by the way Russia's debt is
217 billion I don't have it written
anywhere here but have any billions on
your page you're only half trillion
trillions Russia's only at 217 point
three billion dollars as of February of
2020 I believe mm-hmm are they looking
at the saying we're gonna make a
vertical move in the next couple years
to because we're a little bit more
responsible than others or no that
doesn't mean anything so people ask me
all the time because if you look at if
you if you study the way people think
and I'm talking about without naming any
names the Socialists say that we can
print as much money as we want that lets
say that our debt right now is twenty
five trillion let's round up given what
we know we've just spent as a nation but
the Socialists the the universal basic
income say that you can easily double it
and because we have a reserve currency
status and because we have not seen
inflation in generations we're going to
get away with it in our borrowing costs
are never going
to rise and as long as our borrowing
costs never rise and inflation never
rears its ugly head then we can borrow
to kingdom come
and when these things work they work
until they don't work but at some point
if the rest of the world begins to push
back let's say certain countries emerge
stronger from this global recession than
others it tends to be if you're going to
make a move it tends to be he who has
dry powder the least amount of debt the
most hard assets is able to assume more
leverage and power than they otherwise
would based on looking at the size of
the country's economy in other words to
your point Russia has not weakened their
balance sheet they've strengthened it
and their long term planners China is a
long-term planner as well China has a
ton of debt but China also has been a
lender to many nations with natural
resources throughout the world and
quietly been colonizing a big portion of
the world and they happen to have an
ally in Russia so you can connect many
dots no doubt about it
theoretically no doubt about it but all
of this debt we're taking on does weaken
our position on the global stage I think
you're saying theoretically because
you're being diplomatic but I think
that's more than theoretically by the
way China's number if you can verify
this guy I just want to verify this if
I'm saying this if I'm incorrect please
let's correct it
I believe China's debt to GDP ratio is
50 point five percent which is also low
with rush out of all the names I said
they're low with Russia so it's
interesting how the place I will push
back a little bit though because if you
add up all of the different sources of
debt in China boy they're they're 300 or
above 300 percent if you if you
corporate debt household debt and the
fact that there's a lot of state debt
that runs around in places that isn't
really identified if you did that with
us where would we be if we're right now
106 if you apply the corporate debt and
everything what would we probably in the
upper 200 so they're still higher than
us if you if you take everything
employee
okay China is still higher than us if
you're considering all forms god of
death that's good to know so now
123 trillion dollars u.s. collective
liabilities that we have how do we pay
that off I mean this whole thing about
debt that how do you pay off a hundred
and twenty three trillion all right I
don't think there's any kind of an
assumption about paying it off I think
there's there's an assumption about
carrying the debt how long is that gonna
be carried I mean it's hard to say look
this is you know there are there there
are so many the next generation of
constitutional lawyers is going to be
very busy states cannot declare
bankruptcy it is against the
Constitution of the United States for
the state of Illinois for example to
declare bankruptcy and we know from what
we've heard out of Illinois initially
that they're going to stop making some
payments that there's the potential for
the first time since the Great
Depression
for a state to default on its debt but
the federal government is not legally
able to come in and bail out Illinois
theoretically they're breaking a lot of
laws in DC right now so I'm sure that
they would just pass a special
legislation of some kind and come in and
do it but that would be questioned
constitutionally what the Federal
Reserve is doing right now is also going
to be questioned constitutionally
because the Federal Reserve cannot buy
corporate bonds but by setting up a
separate vehicle through the Treasury
Department a special purpose vehicle
takes me back to my days of studying
Enron off-balance-sheet financing that's
what the government's doing right now
and by a seating control to the Treasury
the Federal Reserve has has lost its
independence if you want to take the
argument to an extreme if Donald J Trump
is Steven minuchin boss then Donald
Trump is running the Federal Reserve
right now and that's legal that's law
because there's four point five trillion
dollars that's going to be directed via
the Federal Reserve and the Treasury and
Donald Trump has said that he will not
answer to anybody even though he has
behaved and he's appointed an inspector
general from his administration but
there are things happen
in America right now and you you started
asking me about entitlement spending and
that's what brought public pensions to
mind so quickly and that's what brought
the state of Illinois to mind so quickly
there's an assumption that there never
be a price to be paid but if you think
about what the average American
households about to go through there are
the makings of a third political party
in this nation to question what is going
on it's very easy to see because right
now there's a large a large percentage
of the US population that has no voice
this has been set for a while though
you're really thinking we can have a
third because everybody's been saying
third political party third political
party and by the way it'd be great but
we've never had critical mass but you
aren't you and I are talking about 30%
of Americans being out of work critical
mass right there you've never had a
critical mass but you've never had this
many Americans who are going to be
focused on who is and is not
representing their best interests how do
you tell between the [ __ ] I mean
everybody can say they have you as their
best interest how do you how do you tell
that apart you know because behind
closed doors who's really leading these
guys that you said Trump let me read
something to you a tweet he sent out
back on September 11 the Federal Reserve
should get our interest rates down to
zero or less and we should then start to
refinance our debt interest could be
brought way down while at the same time
substantially lengthening the term we
have the great currency power and
balance sheet and us the US should
always be paying the lowest rate no
inflation it is only the naivete of Jay
Powell and the Federal Reserve that
doesn't allow us to do what other
countries are already doing a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity that we
are missing because of boneheads
this is 9/11 2019 this is pre
coronavirus to understand that we'll go
from four and a half to zero he did not
know that we're gonna need more for that
you read that you hear me say that what
do you think about it well he's using
the example of the country of Germany
that is effectively paid to take on
sovereign debt of course Germany is also
very frugal
and their balance sheet could stand up
to ours any day but if you think about a
bank let's let's take this to its most
simple terms a bank is in business to
borrow at a very low rate and lend out
money at a much higher rate and the
difference between those two rates is
where they make money and why they're a
bank why they stay in business if you
take interest rates to a negative level
a bank has no reason to be a bank
anymore the bank should just close its
front doors and go away that's what
you're talking about if you're talking
about negative interest rates in America
that's how impossible it would be
that's how crippling it would be that's
why the Japanese bank stock index is
down 90 percent from its highs because
the Japanese banking system has been
crippled by negative interest rates
that's why the European banking system
that index since negative interest rates
were imposed is down 40% negative
interest rates are very much not
they're anti-american they're
unpatriotic they should never even be
considered and to Jay Paul's credit and
those are not words that I use often he
is pushed back against negative interest
rates because he understands the
Pandora's Box that that would open with
all due deference to our president let
me ask you a question president Trump
obviously has never been a China fan and
not unless dicket he's not going to
China fact he's tweeted about he's
talked about it's definitely said China
is not a friend he's not an ally so we
know that right and I think we actually
know that yeah we know that
how so the question I want to ask is has
he been a fan of the Fed pre becoming a
president as somebody who's in real
estate that's how he's made as well okay
is he a fan of the fad or did he always
have issues with the Fed because I'm
going somewhere with this mm-hmm
this is he been a pro you know you don't
know if you don't know the answer it's
fine if you know no when he was
campaigning he was he was very open and
adamant about saying that the Federal
Reserve was inflating a stock market
bubble with artificially low interest
rates that's what he said on the
campaign trail so that's a matter of
public record so let me ask you this
question is is there a possibility even
a possibility that he is wanting to do
whatever he can if it's even possible to
bankrupt a Fed the Reserve Federal
Reserve to bankrupt the Fed I mean you
can't you can't bankrupt the Fed you can
you can always bail the Fed out if your
treasury I know you can but to get a two
point what we get but is he trying to
break the head that's what I'm saying to
go to a point where hey we learned our
lesson now we have to get away from it
is there any possibility that's the
direction he's going again the Federal
Reserve purchasing corporate bonds is in
direct violation of the Federal Reserve
Act of 1913 that law has been thrown
away with the stimulus package because
through a special purpose vehicle the
Federal Reserve can through Blackrock a
massive firm by corporate debt and put
it on the Treasury's balance sheet if
again you take this argument to the
extreme the financial markets have been
nationalized and if you take the
argument to the extreme to the extent
that the Treasury is answerable to the
administration Donald Trump has broken
the Fed and this is something that is
extremely difficult to get your head
around I need to get out more
well I think we all need to get out more
we could agree on that right yes we're
all gonna be happy when we can get out
more but even before the coronavirus I
needed to get out more so I know what
the Federal Reserve Act says and when I
was inside the Fed for nine years in the
heat of the financial crisis it was
debated as to whether we could buy
corporate bonds and the answer was no
and yet somehow because this crisis is
as severe and swift as it is we have
said we're going to set the law side
look the other way and find a workaround
so that we can make sure that we don't
have a full-blown meltdown in the
corporate debt market by the way that
was facilitate
by federer's our policy keeping interest
rates too low for too long you would not
have had a doubling of US corporate
bonds to ten trillion dollars if the Fed
had not repressed interest rates in the
first place so one of my heroes in the
world of finance is Jim grant and he's
always said at best you can talk about
Alan Greenspan not not imposing margin
requirements in 1996 when he said the
words irrational exuberance recognizing
we had a stock market bubble he could
have done something about it then he
decided not to alan greenspan again was
informed in 2003 people are getting home
loans who shouldn't be the subprime
mortgage things going to blow up he
could have made mortgage requirements
more stringent lending standards more
stringent he chose not to so jim grant
has always said that the Fed is both
arsonist and firefighter and that is
that is exactly the same exact case
today
so you break the Federal Reserve Act you
annihilate Fed independence so that you
can come to rest to the rescue of the
corporate bond market that wouldn't need
rescuing had it not been for Fed policy
this is an old strategy Awards it's a
hey Gillian dialectic you know this is
the Hegel philosopher would talk about
create the problem you know blame it on
somebody else then be the one that comes
and offers solution you'll be the hero
oh my gosh thank you so much for coming
and saving us but you're the one that
originally it's very deceptive now the
question you said if that's the case
Trump broke the Fed was that intentional
or accidental that's the real question
well I will say that the disc I will say
that Wall Street was that you you knew
the Wall Street had its pacifier taken
away and there was not a huge whining
among the babies on Wall Street saying
we've got a problem here in the
corporate debt market we've got a
meltdown we might have systemic risk
which is risk you can't contain which is
risk that the Federer's are anything
about and we've got to come up with a
solution for this right now so you might
could say that the
was there I think a lot of people who
would be otherwise known as capitalists
would disagree with you and they would
say if they borrowed too much and they
couldn't afford to service their debt
then let them go out of business so I
think that you will be told that the
need was there but I think that's a red
herring so so let's talk about my friend
[ __ ] capitalist that will say if you
borrow too much that let him go out of
business do you have a problem with that
because the way you said it it seemed
like you do have a problem with that no
I'm saying that Wall Street has a
problem with that Wall Street has a
problem with allowing the
too-big-to-fail companies to go out of
business of course they do okay I'm good
I'm fine with that I told you we're on
the same page here because I get to do
deals
regardless 100% but if you take half you
know they they don't want all their
corporate clients to go away these big
investment banks I want them to stay in
business by being bailed out but then
here's the problem so what kind of a
habit are you teaching if it's the
constant bailouts if I know my dad's
gonna bail me out every time I go do
some stupid he's gonna come and paid
$1,000 bail and I'm gonna get go home
and say I don't worry about it just
don't do it again what's wrong with you
and I know I'm gonna do it again and
he's gonna bail me out what the hell am
i learning what lesson am i learning if
you're not I mean if you look at the
cash flow of major American Airlines
ninety six percent of it went into share
buybacks and we've just wholesale bailed
him out ninety-six percent went into the
buybacks
but right now with the 2.2 trillion was
in their closet they can't do any
buybacks F if they took any money that
was part of the discussion it would
happened that was part of the discussion
we will wait and see
there's also part of the discussion
about not laying people off until a
certain date and time and not paying
executives more than some exorbitant
amount who holds the federer countable
like you know the whole thing with the
odd odd odd it never took place who
holds them accountable I mean we had jeb
Hensarling he was in Congress at the
time he left there's very little
appetite during crises to hold the Fed
accountable this won't come until after
were past this and the people realize
what's been done but right now Congress
needs the Fed badly they need the Fed to
keep the stock market up they need the
Fed to keep these companies in business
they need these companies to
keep their employees but they can't
address the entire problem and now the
great debate is whether or not the feds
going to come in and cross the final
Rubicon what I'm writing about this week
asks one simple question will the
Federal Reserve buy junk bonds doing
something that no central bank in the
world has done will they go that far
will they bail out companies that are
completely insolvent it's another form
of quantitative easing billing well it's
a form of quantitative easing but in
theory even under extraordinary
circumstances you're not supposed to
bail out an insolvent institution I give
you Lehman Brothers that was what Ben
Bernanke went on national television and
explained they were insolvent therefore
we couldn't bail them out AIG was
solvent therefore the next day we did
bail it out how many laws are being
broken right now I you know what I'm
saying I've seen this I'm not an
attorney but I've lost count okay so so
oh my gosh you know the longest time you
know Milton Friedman won everything cups
was that he had a challenge with another
economist was the fact that he felt you
can allow capitalism do its part without
any laws and then later on he came back
and says no if there's one thing we
definitely need we need laws maybe we
don't need a lot of lawyers but we
definitely need lawyers because China I
think back in 2004 they had only a four
in 1994 thing they only had four law
schools and only 2,000 lawyers in China
back in 1994 so there wasn't a lot of
laws okay it doesn't seem like a lot of
them it was reasoning there rivers yeah
and they were poisoning their rivers of
course and now going back to this when
we're talking about the whole Federal
Reserve to go a little bit deeper into
it what have they ever gotten right
because if you look at Internet tech
boom late 90s you oh my gosh you know
look how many billionaires that was
going up as something was going up you
know the mortgage oh look at this stuff
this is just amazing stuff interest
rates you know this is great don't worry
about it it's gonna be alright Bernanke
you say what have they ever gotten right
so there are two people who are my
heroes William McChesney Martin he went
through multiple administration's was
famously thrown up against a wall by LBJ
and refused to back down to
one president after another probably the
most independent Federal Reserve
Chairman of all time he was the one who
famously said it is the feds duty to
pull to take away that punch bowl in the
middle of the party in a congressional
testimony and then you had great big
Paul Volcker who defied defied Reagan
mutiny on his own board and was tossed
out on his ass and replaced by Alan
Greenspan and since then basically
whatever investors have wanted investors
have gotten and since then the
inequality divide in America has gaped
out and so I guess since Paul Volcker
not much has gone right at the Federal
Reserve and you've had two independent
chairman in its history - how scary is
it to go against the Fed if somebody's
running for something and you're being
too vocal about it yeah okay I mean Ron
Paul tried to do it all say I think Ron
Paul he also had another book he wrote
that have to do with the feds right I
think yet I don't know what the title
was but he was also talking about
something with the feds and he got a lot
of pushback and he had a lot of
independence that came out you know
libertarians and independents were all
for him to kind of get him going but
there he couldn't create all the
momentum down to to the end can you
really go to the top and go against that
system a lot of enemies I and I've met
I've met Ron but I was never the opinion
that we should have ended the Fed I mean
we're closer to being in Banana Republic
than we ever have been but if you if you
contemplate what China has done with our
intellectual property and then you
extrapolate that type of espionage and
trickery into what they would do if our
financial system was unprotected good
lord
they would take over the economy by
force so I've never been in the opinion
that we should have no Federal Reserve
I've just been under the opinion that if
you can't have a way McChesney Martin E
or a Paul Volcker running it then you
they should be fired and that they
should be they should be forced to be
independent it's actually in the Federal
Reserve Act that you are supposed to
have a Federal Reserve Board that is
from individuals who are from a
diversity of industries and geographies
you're not supposed to pack it full of a
bunch of PhD academics who've never had
to have a payroll in their life and only
have theoretical models that they put in
place and say I know we should take
interest rates to zero and see how much
that screw savers because they have
pensions for life because their
academics why do you have a problem with
that why do you have because why do you
have a problem with the you know the
whole 17 out of the 17 I think you said
10 our PhD - our lawyers you know what's
the biggest challenge there do you think
we'd have better Fed policy I'll throw a
question back back at you and be
Socratic do you think we would have
better Fed policy if the people making
Fed policy understood what it was to be
on the receiving end of it you don't
have to sell me on that I'm asking why
why is this continuously happening
because for me you can also make the
argument if you go in there to say how
could you be the commander-in-chief of
the of America and you've never served
the military that's kind of tough for me
I mean we don't have for me it was the
last time we had a president that served
in a military it's right it's been a
long time that's how could you be the
commander in chief if you've never
served the military you have to know
what sacrifice means so would sacrifice
the lives of others which one are you
more comfortable with I'm I look I'm a
huge patriot my
my boy would go to a military academy I
mean you're I see exactly where you're
going and and again I think that the
Federal Reserve Act was written in good
faith and that we should have pension
fund managers prior successful pension
fund managers and there are a few state
of Indiana the state of Utah they're
actually properly despite interest rates
being at the zero bound and too low
they're not taking excess risk with
grandma's pension
there are joke you CEOs who have not
spent all of the money on share buybacks
despite the temptation being there and
Federal Reserve policy saying don't
invest in the future you're gonna make a
lot a lot bigger bonus and your stock
price is gonna go a lot higher
if you buy back your shares instead and
by the way money's free borrow at will
and do so but you need to have people
who understand the consequences of
Federal Reserve policy making Federal
Reserve policy and Jay Powell was
actually a kind of a good candidate for
that and he's buckled completely under
the pressure it's funny you say that you
know yesterday we had a meeting with my
cf1 our board was asking me so when are
we applying to get the money from the
stimulus because we can apply for it and
I'm sitting there and I'm saying how
much is it gonna be they give me the
number what's the buy back what does it
look like I'm like you know what we
don't really need it why we apply for it
let somebody else they get it that
needed we decided to kind of get our
finances in order to not have to worry
about a time like this I don't have to
go and apply for getting the five or ten
million dollar check they're gonna send
I had some okay I'm gonna give it to
somebody else not me I don't need to be
bailed out for it but I just think this
approach we're taking a loan for a loan
for a loan for a loan for a loan I mean
when does it ever end so the argument
then becomes about the taxpayer who's
pissed off and saying let me get this
straight you can constantly bail
yourself out and you can constantly go
print money with this quantitative
easing why the hell do I have to pay
taxes why do I pay taxes you can you
know this goes to your argument with the
socialism but why do I pay taxes that's
slightly different than the concept of
socialism because socialism is to give
me stuff right but why do I pay taxes
that's right for my big 40th birthday
lunch there were at the time that I had
lunch with Richard Fisher who was my
boss there were riots in the streets of
Athens and we ended that lunch with me
saying what's your greatest concern and
his answer was I worried that fed policy
is going to eventually land us in the
same spot as where Greece finds itself
back then with riots in the streets now
take my example of the state of Illinois
you're you're a Chicagoan your 401k has
been decimated because you're one of
millions of Americans who've been told
to keep your money in the stock market
no matter what and there's there's
there's no other school of thought
you've got countless investment advisers
all giving the identically same advice
to all of them here so you're joke you
401k holder and you're pissed off and
you've lost a good chunk of your savings
and you know you're gonna have to tack
at least another decade onto your work
life to make up for what you've lost now
the city of Chicago has just bailed out
its pension again so you're told that
your property taxes and your state
income taxes are gonna have to rise to
pay for it let's just say Social
Security and Medicare run out of money
so you're also told by the great people
in Washington that your federal taxes
are going to have to go up as well so
you're bailing out the pensioners you're
bailing out the federal government
you're bailing out corrupt state
politicians and unions who knows though
who have given way too much more than
they could ever afford to pay for and
your next-door neighbor's a fireman
who's living great and he's set for life
these are the seeds of social unrest in
this country you can only drive so big
of a wedge between the haves and the
have-nots especially when you're getting
out the middle class in the process if
you make very very little in America
today and I'm talking about today 25% of
Americans who qualify for unemployment
insurance are going to make more money
in the second quarter than they would if
they had not lost their job that's how
big unemployment that's how big the
stimulus bill is by taxing that one more
time say that one more time so the
stimulus bill tacks on $600 for every
American what they get paid by
collecting unemployment insurance so 25%
of Americans who are going to be out of
the workforce okay are going to make
more in the second quarter April May and
June than they would have had they kept
their job so if you make very little in
America today you're gonna get through
this if you're worth a ton of money
you'd long since gone to cash let's get
honest if you're part of that 1% if
you're in the middle
you're screwed and you're pissed and
you're a taxpayer and that's why I say
this could be such a ground roots source
this this could be a generational change
that brings about I'm looking at Abraham
Lincoln I'm inspired that brings about a
genuine change in how we approach our
leadership in America and I'm all for it
I'm not all for American families
hurting at all don't get me wrong but we
have gone through multiple iterations of
gutting out our middle class you can't
do that for too long you lose loyalty
you can't I mean you want me to pay
taxes I don't know how prompt paying
taxes but I mean do something with the
money I'm giving you and actually
deliver on your promises instead of
taking what if you don't want to do
universal basic income and impose
socialism what if you actually hold dear
to your American ideals and you want to
work hard for a living then you're even
more pissed off well that's the
community I'm talking about I'm not
talking about the community of semi-free
money I'm not talking about free money
I'm talking about hey instead of talking
about thousand dollars Universal income
andrew yang policy that became a hit in
the Democratic presidential campaign
that was going on I'm talking about
rather than that what about if you do
something that is not paying taxes for a
certain amount what for I mean I'm not
anyways that's a whole different
conversation I don't want to go to
another part but there in mind to your
point before you move on the Federal
Reserve monetizing the US debt is what
enables all of this Oh preciate their
role I and I understand that but also at
the same time I want to I want to make
sure that if I am getting to work and
I'm working then I'm the middle guy not
the middle or the top I'm talking to
person in the middle yeah the middle
person is like ah I can't wait to get
these checks gonna be great lots gonna
be better than what I was getting paid
to twenty five percent so making less
than fifteen bucks an hour so you know
how that numbers gonna work out the guys
at the top they're like listen I'm gonna
be fine everything's gonna be cheap I'm
gonna buy stuff on sale right now I'm
gonna make more money today than ever
before
those guys are fine the middle guy
that's doing his part her part that's
the person that I can understand why
they're pissed off why they would want
to see
some kind of reforms taking place by the
way who owns the Federal Reserve or two
main shareholders right now Donald Trump
but that's post legislation that's
decision-maker then I guess I'm talking
about okay I'm talking about there is an
answer to this question there is truly
an answered this question and boy we
waiting for the hate mail when I worked
at the Dallas Federal Reserve my email
address ended in dot o-r-g there are
there are banks that own the twelve
district Federal Reserve banks are owned
by banks in the sense that they Kate
they get paid a dividend from what the
district banks make up 6% and then
whatever money the bank has if it's a
district bank whether it be San
Francisco or Dallas or Atlanta then they
have to pay the operating costs to
operate an individual district bank and
after that every single penny that is
remaining is remitted to the US Treasury
that is why my email address ended in
dot o-r-g not dot c om because we were a
quasi private public enterprise J
Powell's email address ends in dot govt
the Federal Reserve Board in Washington
DC is a bonafide formal federal agency
that is not owned by the banks there's a
gray area there's a gray area and this
is this is up for everybody in tin hats
here you go let's plow it down the
middle the government employees have
permanent votes on the Federal Open
Market Committee the district bank
presidents rotate in every few years
they do not have a permanent vote on the
Federal Open Market Committee so they
have less power the Federal Reserve Bank
of New York however the president of the
Federal Reserve Bank of New York is also
the vice chairman of the Federal Open
Market Committee he has a permanent vote
the only one of the districts who has a
permanent vote on the Federal Open
Market Committee and has the quasi
public private ownership which brings in
the banks that sit on the board that
you're getting to so there is a gray
area
there and the New York Fed does have
extraordinary power compared to any
other district and that power over the
years and prior to the crisis was
corrupted which is documented and the
reforms that should have been made
subsequent to the crisis have not been
and if you want to get angry about
something get anger about that but
understand that the bulk of the power
seat is a government agency or the
Treasury would not have been able to
step in like it has this is like we need
a drink right now so I was going to say
that I can read you need something
stronger than let me say that much okay
so how much do you if you're an
economist and you do this full-time
you've been in it for a while this is
your career I'm in finance you I'm just
sure and you said something about you
start out in finance I think you worked
in hedge fund at one point I think you
did I worked with hedge funds I worked
at a traditional investment bank I
watched what investment banks issued for
the inside outsides yeah I start off
with Morgan Stanley Dean Witter a day
before 9/11 that's kind of how my career
got started you know in Glendale
California was supposed to go to New
York and indeed I was short the sp500 on
9/11 you you what I was i I had I
personally had a short position in the
stock market prior oh well I felt that
the market was very much overvalued okay
and was still going to come down so and
my clients were very defensively
postured also for that very same reason
going into 9/11 my birthday was on 9 17
the day the stock market reopened and I
closed out my position as quickly as I
possibly could because I felt like I had
the blood of Americans on my hands for
having profited from it
small story strange but true what timing
talk about oh my gosh craziness right so
how much do you read into these
conspiracy theories that you hear about
with the feds with the creature of
Jekyll Island NSF how much to go how
deep do you have you ever read the book
or no yeah you have to read the book
your world the six names they owned a
quarter of the wealth of the world
settle etc on Woodrow Wilson saying what
he said I get it I get it I get it I get
it
and back in 1907 when we had a financial
crisis and when JP Morgan brought all of
the biggest bankers together in his
parlor and said I'm not gonna be alive
forever we're no longer an emerging
economy we are advancing to become a
developed economy and like our developed
economy peers we've need a central bank
because I can't keep bringing you all
together to bail out the financial
system every time there's a crisis so
that was the genesis of the need for a
central bank was JP Morgan saying I'm
going to die one day
we need a independent central bank like
the Bank of England we've evolved as an
economy we need a central bank because
of how the Federal Reserve was born and
when it was born much more importantly
it was born headed into a war that
exacerbated and over-indebted a globally
over-indebted situation and brought
about hyperinflation in Germany and
another excuse me a Great Depression in
between that took the world down with it
and brought about a war I want you to
think about that and where we are today
but because of the backdrop with which
the Federal Reserve came into being and
the fact that it had to go into DEFCON
one almost immediately means that the
original people who conceived it were
bankers and had extraordinary powers
since then the Federal Reserve has
become a very boring boring boring place
are there conflicts of interest at the
New York Fed do big banks have more say
than they should in terms of being
regulated yes they do
without a doubt unquestionably but the
Federal Reserve of today is bad for
America which is my subtitle because the
people who are in charge of the
Federer's are don't have American's best
interest at heart
they've put us in a precarious position
financially such that if there was ever
an economic shock their policies will
have left us so much weaker than we need
it to be otherwise and that's a hell of
a lot worse than any conspiracy
theorists up in the middle of the night
dreaming about a Rothschild running the
world because a lot more people are
going to get hurt because you've had
academics running one of the most
powerful institutions in the world how
deep have you studied this how deep have
you gone and who have you had these
conversations with for you to get a
hundred percent certain to know that
there is none of this Rothschild on-ear
that kind of stuff well you just kind of
haven't put a lot of time I just well I
just was kind of working here for nine
years and spent a lot of time the New
York Fed and I saw with my own eyes what
was happening I know that but I'm
talking inception how it got started I'm
talking deaths stand that part of it I
mean that part of it again so if for
everybody who can hear me read the Lords
of Finance read one book if you don't
read any other book read the Lords of
Finance and and it starts off kind of in
1913 1914 and it takes you through some
of the biggest mistakes that were made
at the Fed and other people running the
world at the time in Germany for example
and at the Bank of England and it and at
the BOK de France it walks you through
it and that is a much more valid history
if you will then the creature of Jekyll
Island which brings a lot of history to
the fore but doesn't apply to the world
we live in today but if you want to
understand how the Federal Reserve
evolved to become this powerhouse that
it is read a different book do yourself
a favor read the Lords of Finance and
then you won't ever sleep at night again
because of the parallels that it draws
between now and then fair enough okay a
couple things just just the real cool
questions here since we've covered a lot
of different things already
cryptocurrency any opinions on
cryptocurrency is it you know you have a
whole big camp right now saying this is
exactly why we know we were gonna go to
cryptocurrency this is a time to buy
you know XRP ripple what's your opinions
on cryptocurrency so I think
cryptocurrency is a
modern-day reflection of the disgust
that we have in a lack of discipline and
monetary policymaking it is this
generations gold and my issue with it is
that it is much more convertible as
opposed to physical gold cryptocurrency
is much more adaptable on a sovereign
level so you've already had the Bank of
England you certainly had Venezuela
Russia and China they were at the
forefront of coming out and saying we're
going to have sovereign cryptocurrency
said that we can monitor when everybody
buys in our societies it's going to be
yet another instrument that we have on
top of facial recognition but you've
also had that United States also step in
and say yes there will be a federal
cryptocurrency at some point so as long
as you have that ability to make it go
from something that is in the private
realm to being something that is
sovereign I think that that takes away
its convertibility to gold if you will
so prou yes put a couple new jobs in
there or I'm very neutral on are you are
you in but are you and I own gold but I
do not know you are global not
cryptocurrency
let's talk about gold what's your
opinions today on gold so gold surprised
a lot of people because it got hit
initially when financial markets had had
their initial setback and that I would
like to clarify was more a function of
margin calls you come out recently
I'm very recently I went from 53 kilo
down to 47 K 46k yes yes okay now it's
coming back as the printing presses
worldwide get revved up and people are
like they're not gonna stop they're
already talking about the second that
third the four stimulus bill so they're
just going to print to kingdom come and
so's the rest of the world and which
country can come rollout with the
biggest stimulus package so now you're
seeing gold play its traditional role of
the protector of the hard asset value a
store of value now you're seeing gold
come out and rise and I would suspect
that that should continue as they try
and piss all over the US dollar by
printing to kingdom come
you you're forcing it
for for what foreseeable future like
five years ten years fifteen years
because if you go to last 30 years the
last 30 years if you put it against Dow
Jones Dow Jones crushed gold and last 30
years in the last 15 years it's beaten
Dow Jones and SMP 500 so are you talking
10 20 years well I won't say 10 dat
there are 10 to 20 years because my
crystal ball is not that good time but I
would certainly say if you're talking
about the next 5 years or so I would
certainly think that that was going to
be the case because everybody's of the
opinion that the stock market's gonna
come roaring back and that the Fed is
gonna be able to save the day
I'm not so sure which means that if I'm
not so sure and we're gonna need more
stimulus than gold is going to be more
attractive as a factor of time another
crazy conspiracy theory althought you
see what you think about it how much of
this do you think it's coronavirus and
you know whatever's going on with US and
China how much of this you think is
China saying you know what screw you
u.s. you're playing this hardball with
me I'm gonna come and bull you in a
whole different way that you won't even
pay attention to it
how much how much credibility do you
give to that 5% 1% I'm not going to
answer that question but I am going to
answer the question in a different way
because I'm Christian at heart and I
like to think that nobody would want to
kill people I will say this much and if
you're listening write it down in late
November word had already gotten off of
the mainland that there was a virus in
Wuhan on January the 15th the US trade
bill was signed phase 1 December the
15th excuse me December the 15th I had a
whole month off December the 15th six
weeks later the trade truce was signed
with an out clause a very clever out
clause that the Chinese made sure was in
there that said if there was any kind of
act of God pandemic then they didn't
have to make good on what they had
committed to buy from the United States
within days they announced the first
coronavirus so did the Chinese know damn
well that this thing was running around
the world for six weeks before they shut
down Wuhan yes they did is that criminal
yes it is does it deserve to go in front
of a world Tribune oh yes it does
because we know that it was the
unfettered travel that made this thing a
global phenomena it was impossible to
contain six weeks they knew but they
wanted that out clause and then they
underreported what happened in Wuhan
which a toddler could tell you based on
what happened in Italy based on what's
happened in Germany and in France and
now in the UK with Boris Johnson in the
ICU
there's no way in a city the size of New
York 11 million people that there were
so few cases it's impossible with
similar density to New York so the World
Health Organization should be held
accountable for not holding China
accountable to providing good valid data
so that the rest of the world could
prepare for fewer people to die and
that's what you're talking about to me
these are equivalents to acts of war on
the part of China and then equally
whether you're talking about NPR or Fox
News most major media outlets on both
sides of the aisle came out and
reassured the United States that it was
just the flu within 24 hours of South
Korea's first case being reported the
United States first case was reported
and what we did was dither
we sat on it for six weeks and tried to
reassure the public that nothing was
happening somebody should be held
accountable for that because somebody in
the United States intelligence community
has to have known what was truly going
on in Wuhan we don't have a CIA for
nothing and yet we told Americans for
six weeks while South Korea was testing
everybody and shutting the country down
but it was just going to be the flu so
there are a lot of responsible bodies
right now that have taken us to the
point where we're at inside the country
and in China and they need to be held
accountable so you don't even have to
get on the discussion as to whether or
not that was this was a manufactured
virus and set upon the world you don't
even have to go that far
if we find that in future investigations
then that needs to be prosecuted but if
we just ascertain what is known and a
known hushed up secret that the Chinese
knew for six weeks about the virus
before saying anything on the global
stage to get a trade ill find somebody
needs to look into that because
countless lives have been lost as a
result the damages are in the tens of
trillion dollars we're not talking about
small here if that's the case no we're
not and we're talking about people
losing their family members and we're
talking about trillions of we're talking
about suicides in the future we're
talking about economic hardship all of
this could have been mitigated had China
been honest and had the World Health
Organization made China accountable
because at first they said it's not it's
not anything to worry about one who
first came when the whu-oh first came
out and said we don't need to stop every
let me ask you who do you who do you
trust Elysee you ran Russia or China
China China's got more economic power
because of that or because they don't
have a Free Press and because we can't
really know what the hell is going on
over there well that's just a kicker but
you don't really know what's going on in
Iran either you had global satellite
images in Iran showing mass graves Iran
under report it the same and you can't
tell me that in the cold of winter that
Russia has as many cases as it's
reporting but at last check China 17% of
global GDP they can throw more money
around than anybody else and you just
mentioned two of their allies by the way
so that's why I asked it away I did and
the largest contiguous land border on
the planet by the way between Russia and
China I worry about these things because
I have four children but but China right
now can throw around the most because
they've got the biggest pocketbook it's
gonna be a very interesting what happens
in the next six 12 18 months very
because if China comes out guilty for
having done something the trade
relationships that happens with that and
travel do you let anybody come into
it's it's the consequences could be do
you do you do any due diligence and
looking at 5g or not at all you 5g is
not something that you have strong
opinions on my opinions on 5g are so
strong that I would never let myself or
anybody that I know buy a Volvo connect
those dots because I don't want China
listening to me while I Drive a car I
trust China when it comes to 5g as much
as I would trust buying a Volvo owned by
China so I think it is a matter of
national security
do you social media a lot a lot way too
much how about tick-tock my daughter
daughter okay you know the story behind
to caucus well don't okay got it
listen I'll turn it over to your final
thoughts what what do you imagine the
families watching right now and they're
kind of listening to this and you've
shared a lot we've covered a lot what
words of reassurance or preparation or
anticipation what could you share with
the rest of us the Great Depression in
America was one of the darkest chapters
in US history but it also brought out
the best in Americans Hershey
Pennsylvania exists because Hershey
himself employed Americans construction
workers who are out of work to build the
city this is a time that as Americans we
can come together and not talk about
helping our neighbor but help our
neighbor truly give them what they need
this is a time for America to shine and
I'm involved in a fundraiser where we
are procuring masks to get them to
frontline workers and I'm watching
people open up whether it's food to
their fellow Americans this is our
finest finest hour and this will make us
stronger for it in the end if we open
our hearts and if we have the ability
our wallets to those in need and see our
way through what's to come
I appreciate you for coming out this has
been incredible
hopefully in the future we'll invite you
back and you'll be willing to come back
and sit I'll talk about different topics
as it's formulating we're gonna put the
link of her book below and also you
mentioned a charity you're part of if
you don't mind sharing that link with us
as well look at that below as well for
you to go find out what she's a part of
extremely insightful I think extremely
fair on the way you give your feedback
and point of view and there was so much
to take away again thank you for coming
out and being against somebody teaming
thank you thank you for what you do
thank you you asked one economist we
brought it for you this was a very
interesting interview with the angle she
took on federal reserve or her thoughts
on China what she felt about China known
six weeks before and should there be
consequences to China anyways I want to
hear for you comment below if you
haven't yet I have two other videos I
want you to watch one of them is with a
bio warfare and a pandemic expert that
talked about corruption in China if you
have a watch it's like five six minutes
and the other one is since I'm sitting
on one an economist I thought it would
made sense for you to watch the Ray
Dalio interview we did because a lot of
talk of China was talked about here when
we sat down with them late last year
2019 having said that if you haven't
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye bye
[Music]